[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat
aujourd'hui focus sur les énergies
renouvelables alors que l'on vit une
crise énergétique sans précédent le
gouvernement accélère sur le solaire et
l'éolien avec un projet loi actuellement
en discussion au Parlement sera-t-il
suffisant pour rattraper notre retard
réponse avec le président du Syndicat
des énergies renouvelables les panneaux
photovoltaïques ont aujourd'hui le vent
en poupe mais pour se développer les
terrains manquent comment régler le
problème sans rien sacrifier à la
biodiversité reportage à suivre enfin le
solaire est il entré dans une nouvelle
ère comment relocaliser pour ne plus
être dépendant de la Chine entretient
avec Xavier Barbaro le président de néon
mais d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir
sur notre retard en matière d'énergie
renouvelable c'est parti en France
quelles énergies renouvelables
utilise-t-on pour se chauffer ou
produire de l'électricité spontanément
on pense aux éoliennes ou à l'énergie
solaire mais les éoliennes ne
représentent que 10,3% de la totalité
des énergies renouvelables et le
photovoltaïque que 4,2%. l'énergie la
plus utilisés c'est le bois énergie puis
l'énergie hydraulique arrive ensuite les
pompes à chaleur les biocarburants ou
encore les biogaz et par rapport aux
autres énergies on en consomme beaucoup
les énergies renouvelables représentent
19,3 % de la consommation totale
d'énergie c'est une hausse de 10 points
par rapport à 2005 malgré cela nous
sommes le seul pays de l'Union
européenne à ne pas avoir rempli notre
objectif qui était de 23% et encore très
loin des 33% inscrit dans la loi climat
prévu en 2030 mais avec la crise
énergétique le gouvernement a-t-il prévu
de mettre les bouchées doubles oui
l'objectif c'est de doubler notre
capacité éolienne terrestre dans 30 ans
de déployer une cinquantaine de parquets
au lien marins d'ici 2050 et de
multiplier par 10 les capacités solaires
d'ici 30 ans le projet de loi sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables et censées nous aider à
rattraper notre retard
[Musique]
pourquoi la France est-elle à la traîne
en matière d’énergie renouvelable
va-t-on pouvoir attraper notre retard on
en parle avec vous Jules Nissen bonjour
bonjour Merci d'être la président du
Syndicat des énergies renouvelables on
vient de le voir dans notre data ça
s'intéressant dès le seul pays en Europe
à ne pas avoir rempli nos objectifs
concernant la part des énergies
renouvelables dans notre consommation
finale on se dit simplement mais
qu'est-ce qui cloche chez nous beaucoup
pointent les freins administratifs les
lourdeurs administratives c'est ça le
sujet clé c'est en partie ça c'est un
problème de volonté politique également
de vouloir en faire un élément central
notre politique énergétique mais c'est
vrai que faute de volonté politique
réellement affirmée jusqu'à présent
beaucoup de blocages se sont fait se
sont fait jour et c'est pour ça que il y
a un texte de loi qui va être qu'ils ont
cours d'examen au Parlement exactement
mais les chiffres sont assez édifiants
sur l'éolien en mer ils font en moyenne
10 ans pour qu'un projet voit le jour en
France c'est ça qu'en Allemagne et si ce
Royaume-Uni et eu l'intéresse pareil 7
en moyenne deux fois plus qu'en Espagne
et qu'en Angleterre sur le solaire c'est
5 ans de procédures en moyenne pour que
ces procédures sont aussi longues
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour les
réduire il faut essayer de les encadrer
dans des délais de réduire les les
niveaux de recours sans pour autant que
ça nuise à l'égalité du débat public
mais ce qui se passe c'est que il y a
pratiquement pas de limites temporel au
recours et que les recours entraînent
les recours puisqu'il se passe plus rien
sur le projet et donc les opposants
peuvent profiter pour faire des recours
complémentaires et ça produit un effet
de retard considérable qui fait que au
moment où les décisions d'investissement
peuvent enfin être prises des conditions
économiques peuvent avoir complètement
changé donc ça arrive parfois oui ça
arrive qu'en fait un projet n'est plus
rentable économiquement n'est plus
viable parce que les conditions
aujourd'hui avec l'inflation des mais ça
peut arriver parce que ceux qui ont des
matières premières puis quand vous avez
envisagé de développer un projet il y a
10 ans et puis que vous devez prendre la
décision d'investir 10 ans plus tard on
peut comprendre qu'il y a beaucoup
d'éléments qui ont changé dans
l'environnement la volonté politique
aujourd'hui elle est là sur fond de
crise énergétique de difficultés
d'approvisionnement en gaz là il y a
plus de doute aperçu avec des objectifs
qui sont quand même assez ambitieux même
très ambitieux multiple par 10 les
capacités du solaire d'ici 30 ans
doubler la capacité en éolienne
terrestre dans 10 ans et déployer 50 par
éolien en mer d'ici 2050 c'est ambitieux
parce que c'est réaliste oui c'est
réaliste mais ça nécessite beaucoup de
ambitions beaucoup de volontarisme pour
laquelle il y a un texte de loi qui
vient essayer de débloquer un certain
nombre de choses pour pouvoir réaliser
ces objectifs est-ce que ça a coûté cher
ce déploiement à grande échelle les
énergies renouvelables est-ce qu'on a
les moyens financiers ou est-ce que
quand on creuse un peu en fait il faut
expliquer que maintenant ça rapporte les
énergies renouvelables vu le contexte et
les prix aujourd'hui de l'énergie il y a
quelque chose que j'aime bien dire c'est
faire référence au jour du dépassement
et ce jour du dépassement pour les
énergies renouvelables ce serait celui
d'inversé à partir du moment du jour le
jour à partir duquel en fait la
contribution des énergies renouvelables
au budget de l'État aura dépassé le
soutien financier dont elles ont
bénéficié des chiffres ont été publiés
très récemment on est en deuxième des
milliards d'euros une dizaine de
milliards d'euros puisque pour le budget
de l'État dans le dans le verset
directement obligé de l'État c'est 30 31
millions selon la dernière estimation de
la Commission de régulation de l'énergie
milliards d'euros sur le projet de loi
qu'est-ce qu'il prévoit justement pour
lever ces fameux freins administratifs
est-ce que les délais vont être
raccourcis de manière avec des objectifs
chiffrés
alors sur quelques aspects il y a des
objectifs chiffrés il faut peut-être
simplement préciser que pour l'instant
ce texte a été adopté par le Sénat et
qui va être en discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale donc on peut pas préjugés de
l'année finale mais en tous les cas je
voulais signaler que il a été adopté au
Sénat par 320 voix contre 5 ce qui est
quand même pas du tout ce qu'on pouvait
anticiper au départ et qui témoigne je
trouve dans de la naissance d'un
consensus politique sur le sujet des
énergies renouvelables sur les délais
l'idée d'essayer d'encadrer un petit peu
les choses par exemple quand on vous
déposez un dossier l'autorité de l'État
ou l'autorité compétente à un mois pour
dire si votre dossier est complet ou pas
il peut pas vous laisser traîner pendant
des mois et des mois sans savoir ça dans
mon sens ça va dans le bon sens ensuite
il y a trois mois pour faire l'étude
préalable à l'autorisation
environnementale ça peut pas dépasser il
y a aussi des mesures qui renvoient au
nombre de au niveau de juridiction c'est
un peu complexe mais combien d'étapes il
faut judiciaires en recours doit
franchir pour pouvoir être examiné dans
un certain nombre de cas notamment pour
le biogaz les délais a été raccourci
puisque le Conseil d'État est saisi
directement des contentieux éventuels
dans les sujets il y a le problème du
foncier avec on sait qu'on manque
d'espace pour développer aujourd'hui les
énergies renouvelables et la loi prévoit
c'est intéressant de les développer sur
des espaces qui sont déjà artificialisés
on pense aux autoroutes aux friches ou
au parking est supermarchés
est-ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
chose parce qu'on se dit que si on
manque de surface c'est déjà bien
d'exploiter ce qu'on a déjà c'est déjà
pas mal mais ça suffira pas mais ça
c'est permet de débloquer une manière
législative des choses dont
l'utilisation n'était pas simple donc ça
s'amplifie beaucoup les procédures et
sur les sols naturels les forêts les
terres agricoles et là pour le coup il
c'est un sujet sur lequel il y a
beaucoup de crispations et certains
points justement le risque
d'artificialisation des sols qu'est-ce
que prévoit la loi il y a des garde-fous
alors là j'imagine que c'est un point
qui va encore donner lieu à des
discussions mais dans la version qui
était adoptée par le Sénat le principe
est que ces installations
photovoltaïques sur des espaces naturels
ne seront pas considérés comme un
d'artificialisation il y a quelques
conditions pour répondre à ça mais c'est
un vrai sujet parce que l'ensemble des
maires et extrêmement préoccupé par la
réfraction du foncier disponible la
nécessité que tout le monde partage je
crois de lutter contre
l'artificialisation donc ça ça va
également dans le bon sens après quand
on écoute les associations elles sont un
synonyme pour dire que ça modifie la
biodiversité que des panneaux qui sont à
80 cm du sol ça empêche la repousse et
puis les oiseaux se blessent
oui c'est toute la difficulté d'essayer
de développer des projets d'énergie
renouvelables dans un objectif de
décarbonation donc finalement de
sauvegarde de la planète et de consigner
ça avec des objectifs de plus court
terme en matière d'atteinte à la
biodiversité mais les solutions existent
je voudrais juste faire remarquer que
des installations d'énergie
renouvelables en particulier de panneaux
photovoltaïques c'est facile à démonter
au terme de leur installation si un
moment donné ça doit être fait ça ne
porte pas une atteinte
indéfinie infinie au sol et puis à la
question on évoquait rapidement de
l'appréhension des riverains des
communes la loi propose des avantages
financiers on se dit que c'est malin
parce que ça peut rendre les énergies
renouvelables plus plus désirables c'est
l'expression qu'un employait un espany
une hlmiste en charge de la transition
écologique mais en fait c'est dangereux
il faut rendre ces énergies désirables
il y a plein de façons de le faire dont
des retours financiers aux bénéfice des
communes le projet de loi présenté par
le gouvernement prévoyait aussi de faire
un retour directement au bénéfice des
riverains dispositions pour l'instant
n'est plus dans le texte on verra si
elle y revient au moment du débat à
l'Assemblée nationale en tout cas ça
paraît logique il y a un lien entre le
projet qui se développe sur un
territoire et ce territoire il faut que
le territoire qui joue le jeu de la
transition de la décarbonation puisse
aussi avoir un retour et les maires sont
extrêmement intéressés à ça au travers
de différentes dispositions en tout cas
c'est voté au Parlement enfin au Sénat
ça passe à l'Assemblée nationale on
verra ce qu'il en sortira pour l'instant
ça va dans la bonne direction mais ça va
dans la bonne direction après on peut
toujours améliorer des choses
l'inquiétude aurait pu être que
finalement les opposants à un certain
nombre de projets renouvelables en
particulier à l'éolien terrestres se
servent de ce texte pour transformer un
projet de loi d'accélération en loi de
freinage finalement quand on voit le
texte qui est sorti du Sénat c'est
l'inverse qui s'est passé et je trouve
que ça rend plutôt optimiste sur la
suite alors on verra ce que les députés
voudront en faire et nous on leur fera
des propositions d'amélioration de ce de
ce texte mais quand même je le répète
320 votes pour 5 contre c'est pas par
les temps qui courent c'est quand même
assez symbolique allez merci Jules
Nissen le président donc du Syndicat des
énergies renouvelables merci à vous
merci beaucoup à vous alors on vient de
le voir le projet loi prévu de mettre un
coup turbo notamment sur le
développement du solaire mais on le sait
on l'a dit les terrains manquent comment
y remédier son sacrifier la biodiversité
reportage signé manuelle
la France a pour objectif de multiplier
par 10 sa production d'électricité
issue du soleil d'ici 2050 alors pour y
parvenir le projet de loi sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
prévoit de s'implanter sur des terrains
déjà artificialisés notamment sur les
toits ou les parkings des supermarchés
ou le long des autoroutes mais aussi sur
des terrains dégradés comme les friches
industrielles
et c'est à Saint Romain en Galles non
loin de Vienne qu'une centrale
photovoltaïque vient d'être construite
sur une ancienne décharge de produits
ménagers
en dessous il y a une gé aux membrane
qui contient les déchets donc il y a de
un tas de terre qui a été posé pour
contenir les déchets et là nous on vient
on se posant avec nos semelles là en
béton pour ne pas endommager la géomane
9500 panneaux solaires répartis sur cinq
hectares un projet à 3,7 millions
d'euros qui produit aujourd'hui
l'équivalent consommation de 3000
habitants mais c'est surtout un second
souffle pour ce terrain sinistré
aujourd'hui on a convocation de refaire
venir la biodiversité on a irradié les
habitats invasifs de plantes invasives
qu'on a complètement arraché enlever et
on va les remplacer par des plantes
endémiques on va implanter des haies
bocagères qui vont permettre d'avoir un
corridor écologique c'est ce qui nous a
permis aujourd'hui d'obtenir ce label de
biodiversité positive sur centrale
photovoltaïque de Saint Romain en gagne
les Idées Fleuries pour trouver toujours
plus de terrain comme ici au sud des
Hautes-Alpes ou 50 000 panneaux
flottants ont été répartis sur 25
hectares de retenue d'eau cette centrale
produit l'équivalent de la consommation
de 12500 habitants mais dans cette
traque au foncier en quête de la perle
rare les producteurs d'énergie
commencent à être à court d'idées
on ne peut pas atteindre l'objectif de
la transition énergétique en restant
uniquement sur les sites dégradés donc
on doit s'ouvrir à d'autres types
d'autres types de terrains comme par
exemple les zones agricoles répandues au
Japon depuis les années 2000 la grille
voltaïsme fait des émules en France ce
procédé combine production agricole et
production d'énergie verte sur une même
parcelle à étoile sur Rhône près de
Valence les chercheurs font un test
grandeur nature
l'objectif c'est que ça soit l'arbre qui
pilote ses panneaux en fonction de ses
besoins certains arbres sont équipés de
capteurs de capteurs de lumière
d'humidité de température on a des sons
dans le sol par rapport à l'humidité etc
donc tous ces paramètres sont pris en
compte toutes les X minutes ou X
secondes un logiciel un clean plus ou
moins les panneaux solaires pour laisser
passer la lumière cet été pendant la
canicule ce système a permis d'apporter
de l'ombre et d'économiser près de 30%
d'eau une ferme photovoltaïque d'abord
au service des agriculteurs et non des
producteurs d'énergie a priori que des
avantages à quelques détails près on a
une seule année de recul donc voilà au
niveau des fruits on a eu un peu moins
de coloration quand même le fait d'avoir
un peu plus d'ombre si les résultats
sont concluants ces installations
pourraient se multiplier et permettre
aux agriculteurs d'obtenir un revenu
complémentaire
de leur côté les ONG craignent qu'à
l'avenir l'agriculture soit délaissée au
profit de la production énergétique bien
plus lucrative oui potentiellement
aujourd'hui on a des projets
énergétiques qui sont effectivement plus
rentables que d'autres usages comme
l'agriculture et ça il faut surtout pas
que ça s'oppose et que le développement
des énergies renouvelables se fasse ou
détriment de l'agriculture par exemple
il faut faire des énergies renouvelables
et il faut vraiment en faire beaucoup
mais il faut les faire bien dans le
respect du droit de l'environnement en
prenant en compte justement aussi la
crise de la biodiversité qui est un vrai
enjeu l'énergie solaire est une pièce
essentielle de la transition écologique
d'abord prévu pour se développer sur les
toitures ou les zones dégradées les
parcs photovoltaïques s'installent
pourtant dans nos forêts à
saint-just-et-wacker dans le Gard un
gigantesque projet pourrait bien voir le
jour aux abords du village sur ces
collines
on peut pas détruire une forêt une zone
aussi importante et aussi belle au nom
de l'écologie alors qu'on fait
exactement le contraire ici la commune a
été démarchée par un producteur
d'énergie qui souhaite raser ses 150
hectares de zones naturelles pour y
implanter une centrale photovoltaïque
une déforestation tout à fait légale
pierre crouzier habitant du village
dénoncent les méthodes de ces
entreprises prêtes à tout pour faire du
profit au détriment de la nature c'est
des opportunistes profitent d'un système
et se disent spécialiste de la
production d'énergie à renouvelable
alors qu'ils ont que deux ans
d'expérience on parle pas des
conséquences du déboisement on parle pas
de conséquences d'écoulement des eaux on
parle pas de conséquences de Dupuis
carbone disparu non tout va bien pour
que le projet soit réalisable le plan
local d'urbanisme doit être modifié par
le maire mais quelle serait son intérêt
la proposition du producteur d'énergie
serait-elle alléchante
je suis mère on me dit on ne te loue des
terrains 5000 euros l'hectare ça te
rapporte 200000 euros
200000 euros soit environ un quart du
budget de la commune ces producteurs
d'énergie n'hésitent pas à mettre la
main à la poche pour un adouer les élus
leur faire oublier leur conviction et
obtenir ainsi l'autorisation de détruire
plusieurs dizaines d'hectares de forêt
il y a autre zone qu'une zone naturelle
pour implanter du photovoltaïque il y a
des toits des parkings des zones des
zones abandonnées nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de jouer les riches constamment
on va il faudra bien trouver des
solutions vous allez voir combien vous
savez combien la facture énergétique
pour les communes elle va être on va
être il faudra le trouver le pognon
finalement face à la gronde des
habitants les élus voteront contre cette
centrale solaire mais alors comment se
développer sans sacrifier la
biodiversité l'enjeu est crucial et si
la solution se trouvait en ville sur les
toits de nos immeubles en vertu de la
ripower la Commission européenne les
panneaux solaires seront obligatoires
sur les nouvelles constructions
résidentielles à partir de 2029
[Musique]
les énergies renouvelables
rentrent-elles dans une nouvelle ère on
en parle avec vous Xavier Barbara
bonjour bonjour David
producteur indépendant français full
préciser d'énergie renouvelable
essentiellement solaire plus en France
on est on fait aussi de l'éolien en
France comme ailleurs mais en France on
a vraiment un ex solaire et en
particulier agricolaire au 3/4 on voit
que le gouvernement va accélérer sur les
renouvelables et j'ai envie de dire
est-ce que vous aussi quel que soit
l'issue du projet de loi qui discutait
actuellement par Le Mans
écoutez nous on a vraiment des gens on a
fait beaucoup de choses on a envie d'en
faire encore plus on pense que le
solaire est une très bonne solution pour
l'avenir énergétique de la France on a
de la place on a du soleil on a des
capitaux on a du savoir-faire on a des
industriels qui savent construire des
centrales solaires donc ça pourrait
vraiment être un Game charger pour la
France mais il y a des freins à lever on
est largement dans l'émission mais il y
a des freins levés et en même temps le
gouvernement semble avoir l'intention de
les lever donc il faut que les
procédures aillent plus vite il faut que
les que les administrations peut-être
comprennent mieux ce qu'on fait il y a
peut-être encore une forme
d'apprentissage mais il y a pas de frein
finalement autre que cela ce qui est
déjà une bonne nouvelle on entend
souvent que le solaire est une énergie
qui est ultra compétitive est-ce que
vous avez des chiffres qui sont
indiscutables là-dessus et notamment on
pense par rapport au nucléaire
qu'on a de court terme sur le nucléaire
évidemment par exemple les derniers
appels d'offres gouvernementaux en
France alors ça dépend de la taille des
projets ça dépend de leur utilisation
mais typiquement on sait faire des
électrons solaires à 60 70 euros par
pour donner des repères aujourd'hui les
marchés spots les marchés de
l'électricité en France c'est quasiment
8 dix fois ça le nouveau nucléaire c'est
une fois et demi ça en termes de prix et
l'ancien nucléaire donc complètement
amorti c'était à peu près les deux tiers
de ça mais nous-mêmes quand nos
centrales solaires seront amortis le
coût de production marginal puisqu'on a
pas vraiment de de matières premières à
payer sera très bas donc c'est une
énergie qui est ultra compétitive qui
est compétitif qui est évidemment verte
qui est souveraine puisque une fois que
la centrale est construite en France
elle doit produire de l'électricité made
in France pendant 30 ans même si c'est
composant sont pas tous français et puis
c'est une électricité évidemment qui qui
est locale donc en circuit court voilà
et donc l'idée c'est de ne plus être
dépendant on le voit bien en matière des
géopolitique notamment du gaz russe mais
ce qu'on ne risque pas et c'est là le
sujet de basculer d'une dépendance russe
on pense par rapport au gaz et une
dépendance chinoise et vous me voyez
venir parce qu'aujourd'hui les panneaux
solaires ils sont dans leur grande
majorité produite en Chine les vôtres
leçons d'ailleurs aussi ils sont
majorité produit en Chine aujourd'hui
on pourrait tout à fait en Europe et
d'ailleurs il y a des projets
ré-ernaliser la production de panneaux
solaires le savoir-faire historiquement
il est plutôt européen il était même
assez allemand aujourd'hui quand on
visite une usine de panneaux solaires en
Chine ce qui m'est arrivé à plusieurs
reprises on voit que les machines qui
fabriquent ces panneaux sont européennes
et ce sont des
usines qui sont très automatisées les
Chinois finalement sont devenus bons
dans la production de panneaux solaires
par effet d'échelle mais on pourrait
tout à fait refaire ça en Europe neon
soutient cette idée on a nous-mêmes
signé des lettres des lettres
d'engagement auprès d'un certain nombre
de d'usines qui aimeraient exister en
France et en Europe pour nous montrer
qu'on en serait volontiers clients la
part de la valeur ajoutée dans un
panneau solaire lié aux cellules
fabriquées en Chine qu'est-ce que ça
représente aujourd'hui quand vous avez
une centrale solaire quand vous
investissez son et à peu près 35 40 qui
vont dans les panneaux ce qui veut dire
que la majorité donc on achète à la
Chine même si aujourd'hui on achète
aujourd'hui à la Chine mais qu'on
pourrait tout aussi bien acheter à des
dans des usines europ si le si elles
sont construites le reste donc la
majorité aujourd'hui c'est du contenu
assez largement français et européen
vous avez les structures métalliques
vous avez les équipements électriques
vous avez évidemment tout le génie civil
et l'ingénierie où il y a des très
bonnes entreprises françaises donc
aujourd'hui une centrale solaire même
quand vous voyez des panneaux qui sont
made in China vous avez à l'intérieur du
Bouygues du Nexans du Arcelor donc vous
avez un vrai contenu français et
européen mais si on si on relocalise la
production encore une fois d'une
centrale solaire en France on se dit
qu'il faudra toujours du silicium le
silicium pardon encore une fois ça vient
de chienne non aujourd'hui les les
usines de raffinage de silicium le
système c'est la matière première la
plus abondante sur terre donc
aujourd'hui le raffinage du silicium qui
est quelque chose qu'on sait très bien
faire qui nécessite beaucoup
d'électricité là-bas oui on le fait
là-bas mais enfin ils le font là-bas on
pourrait tout aussi bien le faire ici il
y a eu pendant des années des grandes
usines qui étaient par exemple en
Norvège alimenté avec de
l'hydroélectricité en France on a aussi
de hydroélectricité on pourrait tout à
fait faire des panneaux solaires made in
France mais je pense moi que ça vaut la
peine aujourd'hui d'essayer de
réinternaliser cette production de
panneaux solaires en tout cas ça nous
permettrait d'avoir une chaîne complète
made in Europe et donc en terme
d'approvisionnement d'être complètement
indépendant mais à nouveau même pour un
panneau qu'aujourd'hui on achète en
Chine on met les îles aux États-Unis une
fois qu'il est installé en Corrèze ça
reste de l'électricité made in France
pour les 30 prochaines années après
encore une fois si il coûte plus cher
c'est pas nous photovoltaïques produits
en France au début peut-être pas à terme
parce qu'il y aura des économies
d'échelle bien sûr est-ce que vous
pourrez vous engager chez noen à ne plus
acheter encore une fois ces fournisseurs
chinois il a joué le jeu la
relocalisation quittaire
nous reprend sur vos propres mains on le
dit on l'écrit d'ailleurs on a envoyé
des courriers dans nos différents
ministères pour dire qu'on serait
vraiment heureux de payer des panneaux
10 ou 15% plus cher c'est à peu près le
différentiel qu'on estime pour avoir des
panneaux faits en Europe d'abord je
pense que ce serait une belle histoire
je pense aussi que en terme de de chaîne
d'approvisionnement ça nous donnerait
beaucoup de confort plutôt que de le
nombre de containers qui viennent de
Chine etc on sait que on pourrait avoir
accès à nos panneaux plus facilement
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait faire
avec des Chinois on le ferait d'autant
plus volontiers avec des Européens il y
a plus de relocalisation justement
aujourd'hui qui vont se sens il y a des
projets
qui existent théorique ou déjà on sent
non il y a des ministres il y a des
projets en France comme en Europe alors
il y a eu cette fausse idée qu'on a
entendu qui est de toute façon la
bataille du panneau solaire était perdue
et que donc il fallait se concentrer sur
les batteries ou sur l'hydrogène et
c'est très bien j'espère que en gros que
le marché les Chinois avaient gagné quoi
finalement la bataille et pas du tout et
donc le chinois dans ce dans ce secteur
là comme dans d'autres ont pris de
l'avance mais on peut vraiment retrouver
la capacité industrielle en Europe je
pense que avoir une production
domestique de panneaux solaires comme
d'ailleurs une production domestique de
masques
FFP2 ou autre c'est une bonne politique
européenne et une bonne politique
française allez merci Xavier Barbaro
donc merci
renouvelable merci à vous merci tiens
ici pour retrouver notre souv en matière
de panneaux solaires on se passait
carrément du silicium qui est on l'a dit
produit en Chine
[Musique]
et si au lieu de panneaux lourds et
rigides les cellules photovoltaïques se
posaient sur des toiles souples et
légères bonjour Émilie c'est le pari de
la biennée Éole oui alors cette start-up
basée à Vannes expérimente les cellules
solaires organiques les OPV sur les
voiles de battoir tout commence l'année
dernière sur la Transat Jacques Vabre
avec un test grandeur nature sur la F1
des mers le trimaran océan fifty Layton
alors sur son ma à peine 5 m² de cellule
photovoltaïque mais des résultats plutôt
encourageants puisque non seulement les
cellules résistent aux conditions
extrêmes mais c'est la première fois
qu'elles sont testées sur des tissus
souples et ça marche et ça marche mieux
que des panneaux classiques alors c'est
vrai que la startup a testé dans le même
temps et donc dans les mêmes conditions
en mer des panneaux classiques
photovoltaïques sur un autre bateau
résultats effectivement les OPV ont été
plus efficaces ont eu un meilleur
rendement mais en fait ça dépend sur
quoi on se base si on se base sur
l'unité de mesure de l'énergie solaire
le Watt crête c'est vrai que là pour le
coup les panneaux classiques on fait
mieux le problème avec le wattraite
c'est qu'il se base sur des conditions
idéales on va dire donc plein sud quand
le soleil est au zénith sans nuage ce
qui évidemment dans la vraie vie
n'arrive pas tous les jours et encore
moins en navigation en pleine mer et
justement pour comparer les deux
technologies et hall ne s'est pas basé
sur ces fameux watts crêtes alors c'est
vrai Eole c'est basé en fait sur le
nombre de waters water effectif que l'on
rentrait dans la journée et là le
résultat est sans appel effectivement
les OPV on produit deux à trois fois
plus d'électricité que les panneaux
classiques un résultat rendu possible
grâce à la transparence de la voile une
transparence qui permet de capter les
lumières sur les deux faces pour pour
exploiter la lumière réfléchisse un peu
comme si au lieu d'avoir un seul soleil
vous aviez 1,6 soleil et donc la voile
prend la lumière de partout et c'est
pour ça qu'elle dégage autant d'énergie
c'est ça l'idéal et elle exploite
tellement bien la lumière David que
c'est aussi pour ça qu'elle fonctionne
même quand le ciel est bas lourd et gris
vous voyez c'est vraiment une
technologie adaptée à la navigation on
va rappeler que ces cellules sont
légères souples enroulables faciles à
installer qu'elles soient en plus très
polyvalente elle fonctionne quel que
soit la position du bateau donc le
skipper finalement n'a se soucier ni
d'orientation de la voile ni de la météo
mais ce qu'on peut imaginer Émilie
d'autres usages parce que la formation
c'est bien mais pardon c'est une niche
c'est vrai alors la startup a prévu
d'autres
usages par exemple sur détente sur des
bâches ou encore sur des stores
d'ailleurs des tests sont actuellement
en cours avant une possible
commercialisation et l'enjeu il est
vraiment stratégique car on va rappeler
que c'est les OVP se passent de ces OPV
pardon se passe de silicium à la place
vous avez tout simplement du plastique
c'est-à-dire des polymères cousins du
pété pet donc il se recycle comme
n'importe quel bouteille en plastique
enfin du plastique face pour le coup du
silicium est-ce qu'on est vraiment
gagnant d'un point de vue écologique
alors avec le silicium l'impact il est à
peu près le même que pour le nucléaire
soit selon l'ADEM 60 g de CO2 par
kilowatt alors à titre de comparaison
avec l'hydraulique on est à 5 g et pour
les OPV on est entre 10 et 15 g mais
l'avantage David c'est surtout au moment
de l'extraction de ce fameux silicium
ici on a plus besoin d'un extraire de
manière polluante à l'autre bout du
monde tout se fait en France via de la
chimie et en plus vous voyez on règle ce
problème de dépendance vis-à-vis de la
Chine bon la suite de l'aventure c'est
quoi alors c'est en mer toujours avec
une voile faire tester sur le bateau du
navigateur marque Guillemot d'ailleurs
les essais ont été plutôt concluants car
cette voile elle a pu alimenter de
manière quasi autonome son bateau sans
avoir pu recours presque plus recours au
moteur diesel qui polluent qui pollutant
et puis le nouveau défi c'est en ce
moment sur la Route du Rhum avec
toujours une voile sur l'océan fifty
Layton pour tester sa fiabilité avant
une possible commercialisation en 2023
2023 qui sera on l'a compris une année
cléol a plein de projets elle a
notamment prévu des tests enfin le fait
des tests actuellement sur des ballons
dirigeables elle a également un projet
pour couvrir des bâches solaires sur le
toit d'un immeuble à l'occasion des JO
de Paris et puis on peut également
signaler des discussions avec Décathlon
pour équiper une tente solaire ou encore
des stations de ski pour habiller des
tapis roulants de de remontes ski dont
vous le voyez effectivement et elle ne
sait plus où donner de la tête mais pour
cela il lui faut plus de moyens humains
et financiers et d'ailleurs une levée de
fonds est prévue en décembre l'aventure
ne fait que commencer merci voilà c'est
la fin de pourvu que ça dure l'émission
qui rend les la responsable sur Public
Sénat émission à voir ou revoir sur
Public Sénat il y a bien sûr le replay
sur public sana.fr on se retrouve dans
deux semaines
[Musique]